in February 2013 my wife and I moved to
Singapore exactly at the same time uber
has announced it started operations in
the country now my wife and I agree on a
lot of things but using uber was
definitely not one of them while I was
excited about the technology and how
maybe we don't need to own cars anymore
she felt that every over car is here to
steal jobs from taxi drivers and Sanna
was not the only one
as the ubers Airbnb and Amazon's of the
world what we call online marketplaces
as they started expanding their presence
we have heard all of us countless
policymakers worried about how to deal
with these new risks of job destruction
lower wages and and tax leakage we've
also heard company leaders worried about
aggressive competition from global
platforms eating up their local
businesses and on the rational level of
course I understand after all this is
basic supply and demand economics if in
any market to dramatically increase
supply you should expect prices
profitability and growth to go down for
existing players but in my personal
experience I've also seen the other side
of the story where online marketplaces
like go-jek in Indonesia or juma in
Africa have helped their business
ecosystems and the communities around
them the positive side I have seen
demonstrated itself in a woman a taxi
driver in Egypt that now had the
opportunity to work without the
harassment she faced in the taxi
business it demonstrated itself through
a village in Kenya that got an economic
boost because the nearby beautiful but
completely unknown Lake is now becoming
a national ecotourism spot online
marketplaces will continue to grow and
they will transform the way we shop the
way we travel and the way we transact
with each other so we
really need to understand where is the
truth between those two stories should
we expect more of the bright side or
more of the dark and worry inside and is
there a way to get the first without
getting the second I believe there is as
a strategy consultant I study businesses
for a living and as a mathematician at
heart
I couldn't live with something at itself
was it being equally true so I went back
to fundamentals and I asked the question
what do online marketplaces really do
what do they do well at their core
they're doing something very simple they
match sellers and buyers that's it for
drivers and passengers you get uber grab
in Southeast Asia or didi in China for
matching merchants and consumers you get
Amazon Alibaba or jr. in Africa and for
housing you get Airbnb for fundraising
you get Kickstarter the list goes on
what all these examples have in common
is that they transition this basic
functionality of matchin sellers and
buyers from the physical world to the
digital world and by doing so they can
find better matches do it faster and
ultimately unlock more value for
everyone
in fact online marketplaces core benefit
is that they get us more from the same
amount of effort for example if you're a
taxi driver in San Francisco and you
decide to work ten hours per day then
you actually have in a paying passenger
in your car for four hours out of the
ten if you take this same car and put it
on a platform like uber you can have
paid passengers for an additional one
and a half hours this is the same car
becoming 40% more productive and the
same has been proven true for other
online marketplaces by design they
create more value for the economy now we
need to figure out who gets this
additional value you can give it to the
drivers
passengers more income you can give it
to consumers if you reduce prices or you
can decide that the platform gets to
keep all of it what usually happens is
that all three of them would somehow
split it but what about the rest of us
we can also be impacted without being on
either sides of this business if my
neighbor decides to rinse his apartment
on Airbnb and we have more people coming
in and out of the building more noise
than usual then I am getting an
unpleasant side effect of this
productivity magic this is what
economists would call a negative
externality the negative externality of
uber cars becoming more productive is
taxi drivers seeing the value of their
license to drop by as much as 30% in New
York for example this is the dark side
and this is what sparks street
demonstrations and sometimes sometimes
even violence i profoundly believe this
is avoidable and it became clear to me
the more I have spent time in emerging
markets in fact during my time in
Singapore I spent half of any given week
traveling in the region between Malaysia
Thailand Indonesia and I became a user
actually more of a fan of online
marketplaces that were not that well
known back then but some of them made
interesting strategic trade offs that
dramatically reduced their side-effects
their externalities take go-jek for
example they're basically uber for
motorbikes they are one of the most
liked online marketplaces in Indonesia
and this has a lot to do with the role
they chose to play instead of picking a
fight with every other transportation
option out there they choose to
gradually integrate them within their
own platform so that without leaving the
go-jek app you can check the public
transportation schedule and choose to
take a bus for a long distance then
maybe a motorbike or a traditional taxi
that you can order and pay for from
within the same app if you look at
go-jek today 9 out of 10 previous motor
taxi dry
furs believe their quality of life has
improved after joining the platform and
9 out of 10 consumers 9 out of 10
believe that kojic has a positive impact
on society in general now this level of
trust is what allowed Gajic to grow into
what is today a super online marketplace
for everything from food to grocery even
massages and laundry pickups it all came
from a deliberate trade-off to be an
Orchestrator
of a bigger ecosystem where others also
have their role to play instead of a
single winner hero that takes for
himself what would at the end be a
smaller pie another interesting example
is Junior Juma is the equivalent of
Amazon in Africa but they don't generate
the same level of fear in the small
business community and one of the
reasons for that is because they have
decided to actively invest in the
African entrepreneurs to grow them into
the digital age now keep in mind Juma is
operating in countries with some of the
lowest digital literacy and digital
connectivity scores in the world now
they could have dealt with that the
usual way through lobbying for reforms
and they probably do that but they have
also built Junior University an
e-learning platform where merchants can
come and learn basic digital and
business skills we have studied online
marketplaces in Africa last year and
during that study we have met one of
Julia's merchants his name is Joe Meaux
he was fired from his job in 2014 and at
that time he decided he wanted to become
his own boss he wanted to be independent
he also wanted to never be fired again
so at that time Joe Meaux had no clue
what a business is so he needed to go
through a series of trainings to learn
how to select products how to price them
and how to promote them online today Joe
Meaux has a 10 employee online business
and as a few months ago he just opened
here
very first brick and mortar shop in the
suburbs of Nairobi now through its
university junuh has the potential of
helping a huge number of geomos and we
have estimated that together with other
online marketplaces in the continent
they can generate three million
additional jobs by 2025 and they would
do that either directly or through their
impact on the wider community and
sometimes taking that wider impact into
consideration or forgetting about it can
make or break a platform to illustrate
that let's go back to Singapore so when
we decided with my wife to leave the
country
last year uber decided to do the same at
the same time again we became - we
started to see that pattern but maybe
it's a coincidence in in reality uber
lost the right hail in battle to a
Malaysian born startup called grab now
interestingly my wife didn't have the
same level of concerns with grab because
when grab started it had a different
name it was called my taxi and as the
name suggests it started as a platform
for taxis so when grab started expanding
the driver pool beyond taxis it was seen
as gradual and and reasonable they were
also very careful while doing so they
thought of what kind of social safety
net this should bring to all drivers so
they put in place special insurance
packages and even financial education
programs now compare that with what
happened in London in New York in Paris
where taxi drivers didn't feel that the
platform's understood they had to pay
two hundred thousand euros for their
licence and mostly in loans when you
don't take that kind of social
environmental information into account
you get strong reactions I'm not trying
to argue that the trade offs by either
grab or junior gojek are risk-free
did they slow down grows at some points
temporarily maybe but look at them today
go jack is worth 10 billion dollars Jr
is one of only three unicorns in the
whole of Africa and grabbed well they
pushed out
uber out of the whole region of
Southeast Asia and I also think these
trade offs have nothing specific to
emerging markets Amazon or uber or
others can learn from them and adapt
them to their own realities in the long
run this doesn't need to be a zero-sum
game in the long run and then this is
maybe the Asian side of me speaking it
pays to be patient it pays to reconsider
your goal and your priorities in the
light of a much bigger equation that
includes you and your users of course
but also it includes regulators
policymakers your communities and I
would argue above all includes the very
businesses you are meant to disrupt
thank you
[Applause]